I'm so thrilled to be sitting here with
the incredible Anthony Davis jr. some
thank you so much for taking time to do
this
thank you you're an incredible
basketball player obviously I have to
say my favorite thing everybody talks
about the unibrow but here's what I love
about the unibrow say you're owning it
yeah that's how to do it you got to you
know make some no pomp under you know uh
sardine you own it ain't I really make
it funny you delight me it's already out
there do any notes on me y'all into my
hand I can't say you needed me I've
already heard or I'm in LA - I'm sorry
we don't care so that's perfect I just
have to own things and just let it let
it be known that I I like to wear losing
them in yoga pants and bubbler are you
more of a bird or an Ernie man oh I
think you mean watch Bert is he's in the
uni Pam yeah there you know we got 442
it's a community never got some wood
each other so it's only a few without
here so we all divide there don't you be
a tough life you guys are against
dividing in general keep it together
what I also love about is you're so
expressive on the course I mean with the
unibrow that help can you show me some
expressions down tell me happy confused
morning star we confuse them well here
you go
pair chummy confused and horny in there
but I've been there so I sat down with
your boy James Harden I'd also like to
say my personal friend James Harden I
asked him about his cubes hitch uh
what's your what's your pubes ed tree
you can call natural everywhere
you got the uniboob I'll be there hoping
that'll be good this was amazing thank
you so much engineer this was incredible
best of luck in all the games thanks for
taking the iron see something James
Harden hey James how fit broad unibrow